at CES 2014 Sony showed off a prototype
virtual reality headset the h MZ t 3q
basically a motion tracker put on the
back of the existing head mounted
display they already have this new
version replicates the experience of
sitting in front of your own private 750
inch theater but the device can also
track your head movements allowing you
to look around and pan your view across
whatever virtual environment you're
exploring put on some headphones and you
can imagine that this is an immersive
relaxing way to pass some time on a long
plane ride watching some TV or a movie
but some people have made comparisons
between this device and the oculus rift
for the virtual reality headset from
oculus and if Sony's going after the
same audience their prototype device has
a long way to go but even more troubling
as the potential price again this was
just a prototype of no announced specs
or price points but it's based off
Sony's current headset which retails for
almost a thousand dollars and doesn't
include the motion tracking tech for
comparison oculus 2 now dev kits and
fear machines through Kickstarter for
$300 the Sony HMT headset may not be a
serious contender in this virtual
headset race yet but with a big name
company like the stepping into the arena
and shows that virtual reality is
something that start taking seriously